I had a crush on drew Lucy Hale is used
to keeping secrets thanks to her time on
Pretty Little Liars
but now the 28 year old actress is
finally opening up exclusively to ET
about the pretty little crush that
inspired the lyrics from her 2014
country song you tweeted last week that
lie a little better was about drew yeah
did you mean drew van Acker from PLL yes
I meant Drew van Acker
so for years people had asked me what
that song was about or who it was about
and I was like I should just tell them
and then I was like no I should just
tease people for a little bit so for
years I didn't tell anyone and so
finally the other week I had like it
came on my shuffle and I was like yeah
the song is not true I had a crush on
drew yes yeah years ago did he know he's
now yeah sure does not but he's like
happily with someone and it's all like
done with but now the world knows when
drew van Acker he's a cutie
he's a sweetheart too such a nice guy do
you find that when you're working on a
show you're in such close quarters with
people is it easy to fall into crushes
with Pete absolutely yeah absolutely I
think that thanks my actors can stay
married because it's like woo it like
almost you know I'm older now so I can
like differentiate like real life and
work but when you're younger you're
you're you know especially when you're
on location you're like almost forced to
bond with these people in a different
way and like there's a lot of head games
going on and yeah there's been I've had
lots of little show manson's before yeah
and then we stopped filming or working
I'm like oh wait I don't really like you
never that was become show manses
because it's like for the time being
how I love life now Lucy you know I'm
happily spending time with my dog no I
will say I'm very happy I'm like you
know life is good in all areas
you
[Music]